foreign
news everyone I know how to fix Santa
oh I just need to sneak up on him and
reverse the polarity of his naughty dice
sensor but Santa's always on guard
against attacks just like me hi
hi you'll never be able to sneak up on
him not through space no but through
time probably you see Santa's only
prepared for an attack from the present
so I've been souping up my old time
machine where is it the question is when
is it and the answer is right about
it's so amazing I don't even care that
it's on my foot
I've installed a manual transmission
with a reverse gear so it can now go
backward in time as well as forward
my plan is to back up to the year 2801
when things first went wrong and
materialized behind Santa as he exits
this very fireplace did this building
even exist in 2801 yeah but back then it
was some kind of meat market where
butchers would hook up and grind their
sausages yes anyway once there I'll
quickly reverse the polarity of Santa's
Naughty Nice sensor then return to the
present problem solved
um Professor isn't it risky to go back
in time and change history oh my yes but
I'll go along to minimize the chance of
anyone becoming their own grandfather
these things happen no they don't
[Music]